on december 22nd 1984
cow number 133 on a farm in england
sussex county
began displaying head tremors and a loss
of coordination
it died a few months later on february
11 1985
while other cows began showing similar
symptoms
but it wasn't until september of that
year when a government pathologist
determined that cow number 133
died from spongiform encephalopathy
later called bovine spongiform
encephalopathy
or more commonly mad cow disease
and it would take several more years
until scientists on the spongiform
encephalopathy advisory committee
announced a possible link between the
disease in cows
and a similar disease in humans sparking
numerous efforts to curb its spread
from banning british beef exports to
culling more than four
million cows to banning blood donations
while early predictions estimated the
outbreak would kill thousands to tens of
thousands of people
there have only been 231 human
fatalities worldwide
the majority within the uk however in
2013
a study was published where researchers
tested over 32
000 appendices from british people for
the disease
and they worryingly found that one in
every 2 000 people in the uk
is carrying the abnormal protein that
causes the disease
but are not showing any symptoms at
least not yet
because an estimated 31 000 people are
still carriers of the disease
preventative measures like blood
donation bans are still in place to
avoid
transmission in the u.s if you spent
more than three months in the uk
from 1980 to 1996 you can't donate blood
but as the pandemic rages on blood
shortages are
dire hospitals are struggling to have
enough on hand
and since the 90s new blood tests have
been developed
and general cautions and blood donations
have advanced
so are these bands just overkill at this
point or are they still necessary
when bse is transmitted to humans it's
called variant kreutzfeld jacob disease
or vcjd this is just one of four major
types of cjd
which are classified by how it's
contracted in addition to variant cjd
there is sporadic cjd the cause of which
is still unknown
familial or inherited cjd occurs when
someone inherits an abnormal protein
gene from their parent
and iatrogenic cjd occurs accidentally
in the medical setting
one famous occurrence took place between
1958 and 1985
when thousands of children were injected
with human growth hormone collected from
deceased donors
who were unknowingly infected with cjd
cjd altogether is an extremely rare but
fatal condition it's caused by an
abnormal infectious protein
in the brain called a prion prions are
misfolded proteins with the ability to
transmit their misfolded shape onto
normal variants of the same protein
inducing them to change their
conformation as well
producing a chain reaction that
propagates the disease
and generates new infectious material
this is unique in the disease world
before prions were discovered it was
believed that all pathogens
like bacteria or viruses had to contain
nucleic acids to enable them to
reproduce
like dna or rna the discovery of prions
opened our eyes to a totally new
mechanism of disease
and it's a particularly devastating one
their misfolded shape creates brain
damage which quickly worsens
over time proteins are a very important
part of our body's chemistry and are
responsible for the structure
function and regulation of our tissues
and organs
they are large molecules made up of
hundreds to thousands of organic
compounds called amino acids
which are attached in long chains or
strings
these strings then fold into a 3d shape
this protein folding is
key as each protein forms a specific
shape that allows it to perform its
specific function
but if a mistake occurs they can misfold
or fold incorrectly
which is how an abnormal prion occurs
there are actually many diseases caused
by misfolded proteins
these can lead to a loss of function
like in cystic fibrosis or tay sachs
disease
where one type of protein is misfolded
and therefore can't do its job
they can also stick together and cause
clumps or plaques which can disrupt cell
function
the other way prions devastate the brain
is by creating
holes as they build up they cause brain
cells to die
which releases more prions and so on in
areas where brain cells are killed
holes are created that make the brain
sponge-like
this type of brain damage causes
symptoms similar to other neurological
disorders like dementia
invariant cjd typically psychological
symptoms that affect a person's behavior
and personality develop
first in a few months neurological
symptoms develop
such as problems with coordination
slurred speech numbness
dizziness and vision problems over time
symptoms worsen until the patient is
bedridden
completely unaware of their surroundings
and can't communicate
the disease always progresses to death
it took some years of research to nail
down just how bse spread from cow to cow
and from cow to humans
eventually they identified the source as
their food in both cases
at the time cows were often fed the
remains of other cows so if they ate
infected meat they
too became infected this led to a spread
of bse between cows eventually reaching
a peak infection rate in 1993
of 0.3 percent of the uk national herd
the answer
banned the feeding of meat and bone mix
to farm animals
likewise humans who ate beef containing
infected nerve tissue contracted vcjd
while initially it was thought that
humans weren't affected by the disease
once it was made clear that they were
bans were quickly placed on british beef
exports
cattle over a certain age were banned
from the food chain and
at-risk cows were cold but eating
infected beef isn't the only way
humans can get vcjd and this is where
the blood bands come in
there were four cases in the uk where a
patient contracted it after receiving a
blood transfusion
quickly blood donation bans were put in
place in countries like the us
canada and australia where people who
have spent several months in the uk in
the 80s and 90s are not allowed to
donate blood
this seems like a broad stroke to ban
millions of possible donors from just
four
instances of blood transmission but for
a long time
it's been necessary because it's
difficult to know for sure if someone
has vcjd
there is no blood test that can simply
tell you if you have it
typically a diagnosis is made by
considering the patient's symptoms
and through neurological tests like an
mri which could show
abnormalities typical of vcjd but even
then it's not conclusive
the only way to confirm a diagnosis is
by analyzing the patient's brain tissue
which can only be done after they've
died so scientists are setting their
sights here
if there was a way to test for vcjd in
living patients
then the ban could in theory be
permanently lifted
because prion proteins are primarily
found in the brain
they're hard to detect in blood so
researchers have developed a method to
amplify the prions in blood samples
called protein misfolding cyclic
amplification or pmca
it works by taking advantage of the
infectious prions natural tendency to
convert
normal proteins into an abnormal state
they did this by combining healthy
proteins with a small amount of
infectious prions
and agitating the mixture with sound
waves the sound waves broke up the
chunks of infectious prions
helping them to meet and infect normal
proteins
studies have shown that this method can
accurately detect vcjd
in human blood samples and even
distinguish it from other types of
neurological disorders including
sporadic cjd
in a 2016 study it was found to
correctly identify those with or without
the disease
a hundred percent of the time it can
even detect it in patients who aren't
showing any symptoms
in another study published in 2016 their
tests detected vcjd prions in two
patients
1.3 and 2.6 years before they began
showing any signs of the disease while
these results are extremely promising
it's still early days a clinically
available blood test has yet to be
released
nevertheless some scientists think it's
time to rethink the bans on blood
donations
especially with the implementation of
safety measures like leuco reduction
a process which removes white blood
cells from blood since white blood cells
sometimes carry pathogens
methods like this have already helped to
change the donation regulations in many
countries
around those who are at high risk of
sexually transmitted diseases
like hiv and aids increasing the number
of potential donors is even more of a
priority with the current blood
shortages caused by the covid19 pandemic
since the pandemic began there have been
alarming shortages of blood supplies
for one american blood center 31 of
their locations have a one-day supply or
less luckily changes have begun
in 2019 the irish blood transfusion
service lifted their ban
enabling some 10 000 individuals to now
donate blood
and in 2020 the fda lifted their ban on
u.s military veterans who served in
europe now allowing 4.4 million more
people to donate
with more testing and trials soon this
catch-all ban
should be lifted in the u.s saving
hundreds of thousands of lives with
much needed blood how we treat our farm
animals invariably affects our own lives
mad cow disease swine flu avian flu
many diseases of the modern age spread
to us from livestock
and many diseases like this happen due
to poor and overcrowded conditions in
which we keep these animals
keeping the animals healthy will in turn
keep us healthy
ending the practice of feeding cows to
other cows
was a solid step in the right direction
but there are still
a lot of other bad practices like
pumping them
full of antibiotics that need to come to
an
end and helping in this endeavor are new
technologies being rolled out around the
world
like this silly robot named astronaut
which is a fully automated milking
system
it lets the cows decide when they want
to get milked with no human
input required along with cleaning the
udder before the milking process
being milked more often means the cows
get sick less often
they get fewer infections and thus need
fewer antibiotics
to learn more about this elegant
solution you should watch milking robots
for healthier cows on curiosity stream
a part of the european inventor awards
series
all episodes in the series are overviews
of cutting-edge technology that is
working to solve our most complicated
problems
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high-quality
documentaries like this one
and now curiositystream has partnered
with us to offer an
incredible deal by signing up to
curiositystream
you now also get a subscription to
nebula nebula is a streaming platform
made by me and a hundred other
educational youtube content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos and podcasts
ad-free and a place where we can
experiment with new
original content by signing up to the
bundle deal
you'll get access to both
curiositystream and nebula
our newest project is modulus a podcast
where we talk to the people behind the
science we explore here on youtube
the latest episode is about unlocking
the intelligence of the octopus
where we interview people who have spent
their lives caring for
and studying these remarkable creatures
you can learn about their stubborn
personalities
and how aquarium workers have to keep
redesigning their enclosures because
they
always manage to escape by listening to
modulus ad-free on nebula so by signing
up at curiositystream.comrealscience
you'll get a subscription to
curiositystream and a subscription to
nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year signing up is also the best way to
support this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you